in the latest blow to russia's dwindling
civil society the supreme court there
has ordered the liquidation of one of
the country's most prominent human
rights groups memorial was founded in
1989 by soviet dissidents including
nobel peace prize laureate andre zakarov
the group defends the rights of
political prisoners and helps victims of
soviet-era repression prosecutors said
the organization violated a law on
foreign agents on multiple occasions
memorial and its supporters say the
accusations are politically motivated
for more on this let's bring in
moscow-based journalist felix light
felix welcome to dw why did the russian
supreme court shut down this
organization
well rebecca this as many sort of things
are in the russian judicial system it's
sort of a story in two halves you know
on the one hand we have sort of
technical violations of russia's very
controversial foreign agents law that's
the sort of the the technical sort of
premise on which memorial has been just
shut down today but of course you know
in general this case is seen in sort of
a slightly different light memorial has
been famous for a couple of things but
most importantly are
sort of investigating these stalinist
crimes the repressions of the 1930s and
that is very much upset sort of uh much
of the russian sort of contemporary
political establishment and
significantly the security services who
are very very influential in the current
russian government and so what we saw
today and from the sort of the
prosecutors who spoke in the supreme
court was almost an indictment of these
attempts to sort of memorialize the
style and its crimes prosecutors argued
that russians shouldn't pay attention to
these uh sort of the to these crimes
they shouldn't be as they said ashamed
and they should sort of uh
revel in their sort of their let the the
legacy of the victory in world war ii so
i think this was a sort of a case that
really struck at the heart of the sort
of the the the rhetoric of much of the
sort of the the current russian
political system around
memorializing stalin's role in uh in the
second world war and really trying to
sort of gloss over a little bit these
the crimes that that period was sort of
was famous for as well
now memorial says it's been a target of
the same repression it's been trying to
protect people from and that the move is
politically motivated are they right
well certainly many many people have
said that you know it's it's very
difficult to sort of to make a sweeping
judgment but certainly i think
memorial's allies are clear that this is
about sort of overstepping the lines the
red lines sort of delineated by the
kremlin of course memorial was not just
sort of famous for its work on history
uh you know in more recent years as sort
of russia took its authoritarian turn
memorial was very active in producing
very sort of uh human rights orientated
projects sort of supporting our
political prisoners you know people
jailed at protests in russia so you know
there were almost any number of things
on which memorial could have sort of uh
sufficiently irritated influential
security services or the kremlin are
sort of through its actions so i think
it's it's difficult to say precisely
what this is motivated by but there is
certainly no shortage of potential
causes for for irritation from the
kremlin with memorial
now i feel like this is a supreme court
ruling can it be appealed
well technically i suppose yes whether
it can be taken to sort of the european
court of human rights it can be taken to
the european justice system but i mean
the russian justice system has generally
although it is sort of nominally
subscribed to things like the european
human
court of human rights it does not
generally respect their verdicts and so
we may see this case go on but i think
sort of nominally for memorial as a sort
of a legal organization this is very
much the end of the road it's possible
the organization will find some way of
surviving in future but it will not be
as a sort of a legally constituted civil
organization as it has been in the past
right felix like journalist in moscow
thank you very much for your time